partly thanks to new technology we've
become obsessed by the idea of finding
an amazing character called the right
person back in the olden days you may do
you just got together with someone
because their land was next to yours and
your plow perfectly complemented their
oxen it was all pretty practical but now
we're romantics with laptops out to find
the ideal fit someone who's beautiful
who totally understands us unfortunately
it's pretty hard so many people aren't
quite right but still we keep bailing
they must be out there that's what the
stories have told us since childhood but
perfection is at best for angels only a
perfect seeming partner might appear
compatible in so many ways but still we
might come to blows over the color of
the curtains tea versus coffee or
children's names the real challenge of
relationships isn't to find the perfect
match it's to negotiate the differences
without panic or nastiness and stop
blowing up perfectly good relationships
from mistaken dreams of flawless
scenarios learning to give up on
perfection may be just about the most
romantic move any of us could make
you
you